javon what's going on
hey i'm i'm doing good you know i'm just
uh happy to be here i'm happy you're
here too i think i speak for all the
euphoria fans who were watching the
finale yesterday to say that we're not
well we are shook and we're so sad about
what happened to ash
[Music]
when did you first learn about ashtrays
fate in the finale and also given that
there were so many changes this season
was he always supposed to die
so pretty crazy right so before
it was
angus so fez that was supposed to die
and
about like a day before we ended up
filming i figured out that i was
supposed to die
it was like crazy because then we had to
rewrite the whole script of like that
whole ending part
it was insane that that ended up being
the ending of it all and you know it's
not confirmed that ashtray is dead i it
looks like he got shot right but i mean
he's one he's he's one bad kid so you
know he might still be alive out there
you never know you know what you're
right we didn't get a definitive clear
answer yet i love that tease hey listen
you never saw him in like that pool of
blood like on the ground you know you
never saw any of that so you know you
never know i was watching through my
hands so i can't even say for sure dude
because when it was happening i had to
look away i did but listen the finale
did bring the premiere full circle
circle so how did that flashback episode
kind of inform not only your character
throughout the season but like why he
killed custer in that last episode
man i think just like ashtray was just
kind of just going you know just he
really snapped that last episode that
was like his like breaking point and you
kind of like see like that he's still a
kid because a lot of people treat him
like an adult because of the actions he
does but you really see that he's a kid
and he's vulnerable at the end of the
day like he doesn't show that often but
when he does like it's it's it's
noticeable that he's a kid but also
proves that he is a true ride-or-die
because when things got crazy he stepped
up right
right no no doubt he's definitely a ride
or die for angus you know it's as that's
his main thing it's angus because that's
all he got
so he's all about protecting him
speaking of angus what was it like
working with him this past season tell
us a little bit about your guys's bond
off camera man we're going to last
season we just like we had a ton of fun
yeah he's a super chill guy you know
super laid back so like on set with them
it's a lot of fun and we had a really
good chemistry so you know when we were
both playing our roles it was easier to
build that ashtray and says chemistry um
because we were doing that so well off
camera
i love it you know i got to get your
reaction to something that the fans were
quite smitten about and that's fexie fez
and lexi what did you think of that
relationship
i thought it was a really cute
relationship but i hope if we go far in
season three i thought it was a really
good bond and it was good for him and it
added you know that extra layer to his
character that was just really cool i
really need to know what he wrote lexi
in that card that fell out of his pocket
during the raid man
no i wish i could have figured that out
i was thinking about that when i was
watching it though yeah exactly well
listen you know ashrae also took down
nate's dad cal earlier this season
what was it like filming that scene with
eric all tied up in their apartment
so filming with eric man you know it i
felt really bad because the gun it's
like it of course it's rubber the bottom
of it that i was hitting him with but it
was it was still pretty like it was
pretty hard so when i was hitting him in
the head like we had to do it like for
hours and hours and hours on end so he
like started getting really hurt and he
would always joke about how he
um you know got concussed by that and i
don't know if he did or not but did you
really go for it
crazy yeah i really want
he's extremely talented he's an amazing
actor so he was able to like add that
extra little flavor i love it uh so what
was your last date on the set like do
you remember what your final scene was
for this season
the final scene was me getting really
really dirty in the bathtub because like
the bullets were all over the place and
um they had to like put like all this
dust on me
and it took forever to get out like i
had to fly home that night
and like i had to like shower and it
took so long to get it out because it
was like all stuck to me but oh wow the
last scene was like it was sad because
like i knew that was probably gonna be
the last time i'm gonna be on euphoria
so it was
you know just it was a bit crazy knowing
like this is where i started too
you know they really put you through it
but y'all put us through it too as fans
i mean we have been on a roller coaster
of emotions watching season two what has
it been like for you to kind of see the
reactions i mean i feel like y'all have
become memes every week that this a new
episode dropped
yeah no there's definitely been a lot of
memes about
pretty much the whole cast right um but
with like me specifically the memes are
like hilarious i love all my fans and i
just like i just think y'all do like
amazing even with like the edits they
make like it's even making me sad and i
know
that it's it's it's all fake you know
the support has just been incredible and
i just i just really support all like
i'm just really happy about it so you've
seen all those r.i.p ashtray memes that
are floating around the internet today
no but we'll do it and then they'll put
like the pigeons like flying
and beyonce in the background
like the whole thing right yeah and then
like the halos they got the whole floor
and they're like wow okay so yeah you're
back in school for the first time since
second grade are you getting recognized
from the show
i am i am you know and i just um
um i'm cool with it though like i um
it's it's a bit interesting being back
in school for the first time since uh
second grade though it's a big change
and you know uh math is a struggle
because it's just
it's hard because the teachers don't
just work on you with one-on-one you
have to move with the classes so it's a
it's a bit hard but most people are uh
super respectful about it i hate to
break it to you you won't need that math
later i promise
you just kind of exactly
geometry you know i'm not going to use
any good stuff that's so funny hey
listen i got to ask you do you think any
high school is like euphoria you're
literally the only cast member that we
can ask
man i don't think it's anything like
that no i mean some parts of it i guess
um like the you know the emotional part
of it all but it's definitely like an
exaggerated version it's like um
it overall it's like there's something
crazy drugs all over the place i'm happy
to hear that i'm happy to hear that uh i
want to ask you about some other
projects real quick you shot umbrella
academy i know there's not much you can
say about your character but can you
give us a little something are you in
scenes with elliot paige and the academy
give us something a lot of people are
thinking like i'm gonna be joining like
the academy and it's really cool like
seeing like all the theories that
they're making on it but the jack
blackman and um jeff king did an amazing
job on just writing my character and i
cannot wait for you guys to see like how
he came to life because it's it's really
really cool damn you know what's really
cool is i have to imagine that a few
celebs have dm'd you who were you most
surprised by i actually saw alicia keys
and swiss beads up in your instagram
comments and i even see her above your
head right now
oh yeah right no you know um at least
you guys um she's basically my aunt you
know we call her um on tv she's um
she's just like she's
she's just like my aunt so you know
we're super super close and same with
swizz we're all really close have any
celebrity dms you about their love for
the show
a few um
hasty uh was one of them so you know
there's been a few celebs like that but
uh
yeah it's pretty cool seeing people dm
and like talking about how they love my
character and stuff like that so sweet
all right javon clear this up for us
because a lot of fans there's a lot of
fan theories out there but one of them
is that tom holland made a secret cameo
in euphoria this season true or false do
you know
i do not know i wish i could answer that
for you guys but i honestly have no clue
if he did or not because people were
saying it was like he was in the um
scene at the very end right
player yeah
like i like his play right now i got no
clue i wish i could tell y'all okay i
love it real quick what's next for you i
hear your training for the 2024 olympics
is that true
[Music]
that's the goal you know i would love to
go pro but what's next for me is uh
eastern qualifiers for boxing okay right
and then going to nationals so eastern
qualify is like a step four nationals
and then samaritan and umbrella academy
dropping those are my my two next things
and you know um other stuff i can't
really talk about now sure i i know
there's gonna be stuff lining up for you
so congratulations enjoy the ride we
love seeing you on euphoria but i can't
wait to see what you do next brother
thank you so much i appreciate you
[Music]